I've never heard anything like that you
could hear people basically begging for
their lives just like a waterfall of
fire and flame I heard a lot of screams
and I could see people banging on the
windows it was fire all around it was
horrendous
she was screaming I've got a baby please
help me go I can't get out I'm trapped I
need to save my baby in my 29 years
being a firefighter I have never ever
seen anything of this scale this is what
Grenville tower used to look like a home
to hundreds of people built in the 1970s
recently refurbished a familiar sight
too many people traveling in and out of
London it's in Kensington a name
synonymous with wealth but this is an
area of social housing the people here a
blend of nationalities living in the
heart of one of the world's most diverse
cities at five minutes to one the fire
brigade summoned here to a hellish
inferno a 24 story building gripped by a
fire that got ever more intense at a
time when so many people were at home
asleep it was just like a waterfall on
the left-hand side a fire and flames but
now it's all to the right of the bill
that that part there I also went down
the left-hand side of the building as
well dozens of fire engines attended the
scene along with police ambulances and
crowds anxious onlookers friends and
also those who'd escaped what caused
this will of course be investigated but
one resident told us he believed the
fire had started in his neighbor's flat
sparked by a faulty fridge it's by
chance that we had a knock and the guy
who not so happens to be the guy whose
house was the cause of the whole thing
this his fridge he explained to us as he
came down
afterward someone's outside the building
he explained to us that he was true to
his fridge which exploded there's a law
on a fourth floor and well you think
everyone inside the block is I mean
evacuate enough now how do you know how
do we know cause the face we're
extremely quick so what do you do if
you're confronted by this nightmare well
this is the advice given to residents in
Granville Tower told to stay put in
their flat unless a fire actually
reached them many chose to ignore this
they chose to flee I've opened a window
and I heard some woman's scene is
getting bigger is getting bigger so I've
gone out to the hallway I've looked for
this fire oh I see smoke everywhere I've
opened the door and the neighbors were
the end and the people screaming the
firemen didn't get down the stairs so I
grabbed a little girl grab my girlfriend
Rena anyhow I heard a lot of screams and
I could see Alfre hand side I was
looking up and I could see people
bending on the windows and it was fire
all around him it was horrendous we saw
people from the 14th floor crying people
from the 16th floor my neighbor his aunt
was struggling I told him where's your
dad because I know his dad and he said
to me he's indoors he can't walk a
certain let's go and when we went try to
get in the Marcus know where you can get
me I was going through the floor the
fire brigade we had their oxygen we
never had the oxygen so what just have
to leave so there were firefighters
inside the building evacuated just came
in tried to evacuate the people telling
them to God but he told us to stay in
but I have to open the door and to get
out there's a lot of people on the upper
floors
flashing their torch lights and the most
upsetting thing about it all was
you could you could make out there was a
couple of young kids with flashlights
waving waving at people to try and help
them you can hear a lot of screaming
saying help me please please please and
it's just really emotional and sad to
hear
daylight comes early at this time of
year what we saw was hammering around
the tower a carpet of debris charred
possessions but also the industrial
cladding that had burnt from around the
building hundreds of emergency personnel
but inside look to the left of your
screen you can see what appears to be a
resident still in their flat peering out
while three storeys above them this
building burns we don't know what
happened to this person but a story
that's been told repeatedly is one of
utter desperation of people in this
tower trapped and jumping for their
lives
I did see a few people jump people were
jumping and I think at that point it was
you leave a jump in trying to save your
life you might break a few bones or get
engulfed in that flame I saw two people
jump from the right-hand side from I
think I have a froth from 10 to 15 I
couldn't tell you which broad I couldn't
tell you if there were adult so I
couldn't tell you if they were kids or
teenagers all I could see is two people
flinging themselves off the thing people
were telling me other people are doing
it on the other on the other side as
well
there's just one staircase one in one
outside if you can't get to them
staircase you are not getting out that
building there's only one way out that
building unless the jump being trapped
in a burning building is many people's
idea of a nightmare for some there was
relief in simply surviving want to wake
you but for others the trauma of
separation of not knowing what has
happened to friends and to loved ones
the woman sounds like calm she wasn't
panicked or anything and I said what is
your husband she said he's talking to
the emergency and I said waiting to come
out she said they tell us to stay in we
cannot come out and
I said what did they ask you to do she
said they asked us to cover the the
doors with towels and she said but the
fire is coming heavily and then about I
think 1015 minute later we phoned them
back and I said where is your husband
she said he's still talking and they
said they're coming to us and I said
what happened she said the last thing
she said smoke is coming heavily through
the door into the flat that was the last
time could you just sent out a message
about 12 hours ago to say that she was
trapped and that everybody should pray
for her we've been to every single place
that they've asked us to go to
we've separate our families in two
different places some are contacting
hospitals and we're just wandering on to
look for them since this morning who's
helping no one we're doing it ourselves
and behind them the flames burnt on
relentlessly the capital's worst Inferno
for many many years
a unprecedented incident in my 29 years
of being a firefighter I have never ever
seen anything of this scale our first
fire engines were unseen in under six
minutes crews wearing breathing
apparatus and extended duration
breathing apparatus have been working in
extremely challenging and very difficult
conditions to rescue people and to bring
this major fire under control
at this time I am very sad to confirm
that there have been a number of
fatalities
ESCOs amidst the trauma and the grief
the best side of humanity emerged to
people and organizations rushing to
offer food water clothes and shelter
many thousands of pounds have already
been pledged to help and that sum is
growing very rapidly the questions that
will now follow and not just about how
this fire started but why it grew so
huge and so
fast and if that can happen to Grenville
tower could it happen somewhere else the
focus of the experts today
is the search and rescue very soon I'm
afraid I'll move on to recovery but
there are genuine concerns reasonable
concerns that have been raised through
the course of the night and it's really
important that these questions are
answered this building has just been
refurbished a process that took around
two years and cost millions of pounds
but residents here have long alleged
it's unsafe just seven months ago
one group predicted a catastrophic event
a prediction that today came grimly true
there was an issue a few years ago where
there was a small fire and there was
concerns from the TMO residents
regarding this building and the safety
of this building there was a lot of
worries and this was one of the worries
that one day that something like this
could happen
Grenville Tower was built to the
standards of the 1970s just one
staircase no central alarm and no
sprinkler system investigators will want
to know if the cladding put around it
resisted a fire or made it worse there
has been a response from Ryden the
company that did the building work it
said we will cooperate with the relevant
authorities and emergency services and
fully support their inquiries into the
causes of this fire at the appropriate
time the government has set checks will
be carried out into all tower blocks
that had similar refurbishments
there has been heroism today and people
have survived an appalling experience
but many others have died and lessons
will have to be learnt a knight who
shocking events will reverberate for a
very long time
Adam Parsons Sky News